I did not know that there is any
improper use of customer funds
everybody wanted to find the chosen one
the genius that person was sandbank and
freed and the company that he ran was
FTX FTX is a crypto exchange Sam was the
founder of FTX and the chief executive
FTX grew in about three years exploded
onto the scene had the backing of
celebrities FTX is the safest and
easiest way to buy and sell crypto it's
the best way to get in the game at the
heart of this you have an incestuous
relationship between two companies that
were supposed to be separate FTX and
Alameda that was so much alleged misuse
of funds it all came crashing down in a
matter of days when FTX collapsed I
ended up losing a 2.1 million dollars
I could just say this is one of the
biggest frauds in American Financial
history Regulators fell for it Venture
capitalists fall for it everyone fell
for the legend of Sam
foreign
almost universally known as SBF or Sam
came from relative obscurity to King Of
The Hill in crypto within just a few
short years he's the son of law
professors he went to mass Camp he went
to MIT and then after graduating from
oit he went to Jane Street which is one
of the world's biggest market makers
trading firms if you think of sandbag
and freed you think of curly messy hair
and cargo shorts he barely sleeps he
sleeps in the office he sleeps in a bean
bag people look for geniuses they look
for the key man he was like Elon like
Zuckerberg he was just Sam he was SPF he
wasn't a gene Street for very long the
phrase he used once was neutral but a
waste of brain power we went to work at
the Center for Effective altruism like a
think tank that encourages people to
give away lots of their money in certain
ways he was working at the charity
during the day and trading crypto all
night he talks about how he wants to
accumulate as much wealth as possible to
distribute it to people who need it as
fast as he can that's where the idea for
Alameda came from that they were going
to get into this market and use sort of
traditional Finance strategies to make a
load of easy money in crypto
in 2017 some found Alameda research
which was a proprietary trading firm and
Market maker imagine it being pounded in
his basement five or six people College
roommates old friends of Sam from math
Camp the prices of cryptocurrencies like
Bitcoin were different on different
exchanges in different countries if you
bought and won and sold in another you
could make money for free because the
market was inefficient supposedly this
is where he made enough money to get
Alameda research rolling even at that
point there were people who thought that
what they were doing was too risky so
one of their earliest investors walked
away FTX which is the company that
people have heard of comes out of
elementa it's basically the same team
2019 they're talking about hey maybe we
should found our own exchange FTX
exploded into the mainstream
I think we're pretty ambitious about
about fds and certainly we're aiming to
become you know the biggest crypto
Exchange
yeah
2021 was the year where FTX really burst
onto the scene The Wider crypto industry
was also exploding into the mainstream
at the end of 2020 there was some
institutional buy-in a lot of interest
in digital assets like Bitcoin it signed
a sponsorship deal with Mercedes Formula
One
signed up Tom Brady and Gisele Bundchen
it's not that this is big it commanded a
mainstream awareness that perhaps no
other exchange has enjoyed
[Music]
he's everywhere and it's the one that
you mentioned when you're talking about
well there's a lot of quite sketchy
shops out there in crypto ftx's where
they do things properly my name is Sunil
cavouri after graduating from University
I joined Deutsche Bank and worked at JP
Morgan Stanley over 10 years ago I left
the city I trade for my personal account
as a retail investor since 2016 or so I
invested quite a bit into crypto I had
six seven million dollars on FTX at the
end of 2021 they were promoting it to
retail investors and saying if you want
to gain crypto the safest ways to get to
crypto is use FTX July 2021 FTX closed
the funding round of 900 million dollars
which valued the company at the time at
about 18 billion Within
two or three years this thing
worth 32 billion dollars the company is
worth more than Deutsche Bank was at the
time that is unbelievable
investors were incredibly Keen to get a
piece of the crypto action it seemed
like the market was only going up has
investment from a whole bunch of huge
names like Sequoia like Paradigm temasek
from Singapore you've got SoftBank tiger
Global you've got the Ontario teachers
pension fund just these huge investors
and Blackwell I mean a traditional
Finance who are very skeptical about
crypto they invest in FTX Vader than
Finance so I I thought the safest place
to park my money was obviously FTX
before you know it he's making comments
to the Ft saying oh yeah at some point
I'd quite like to buy Goldman Sachs
[Music]
it's FTX it's a safe and easy way to get
into crypto
yeah
yeah and I'm never wrong about this
stuff never
one of the biggest highs for the
exchange came in February 2022 when it
managed to score a big Super Bowl ad I
left my cane in there what what
do you mean hey that's an expensive cane
Larry David was the star of the FTX ad
and then in June it also secured the
naming rights to the Miami Heat NBA
stadium in some ways what made Sam
special was the mainstream acceptance
that he got at one point he was
literally sharing a stage with Bill
Clinton and Tony Blair something about
Sam
just drew in really intelligent people
so there's a really important stage in
the narrative Arc if you like for FTX
around May 2022. there was a so-called
stable coin and an Associated crypto
this Terra lunar pairing that just
unraveled in dramatic style it took down
with it lending Platforms in crypto a
bunch of trading Platforms in crypto and
who was there to pick up the pieces
sandbank them free RTX CEO Sam bingman
free discussing his thought process
behind offering crypto company bailouts
saying it's quote worth incinerating a
small amount of money to keep crypto
infrastructure going he was the lender
of Last Resorts and Wealthy enough to be
able to plug the Gap when bits of the
industry got themselves into trouble it
only took a few months come November for
everything to come crashing down on the
2nd of November poindeska raised
questions about ftt Alameda was listing
as an asset very very large Holdings of
ftt a token that is issued by FTX State
control the supply the equivalent of
counting your own stock as an asset on
your balance sheet ftt is a token is not
widely held or traded it's not like
Bitcoin Alameda the market making arm
that is supposed to be separate from FTX
was holding over five billion dollars
worth of ftt token that is a significant
figure the relationship between Alameda
research and FTX might not be quite what
everybody thinks it is and a lot of the
supposed assets the Alameda research has
on its books are actually tokens that
are created by FTX out of thin air when
the coindesk article came out and
obviously I feel really stupid now so
saying it I wasn't personally I wasn't
too concerned it focused on the Alameda
balance sheet rather than
FTX FTX is an exchange whereby you you
trade assets Alameda is a prop hedge
fund totally separate and they trade
their own balance sheet I mean that's
the
supposed to be I mean why would I assume
otherwise so there's various bits of
lending going on here that are backed by
these ftt tokens
that are only worth something if we all
kind of look around the room and agree
that they're worth something but
actually they're worth absolutely
nothing they're like loyalty tokens for
FTX they enable you to trade on on the
platform and get certain discounts are
they money that's a huge assumption
my name is Nicola white I'm the CEO of
b2c2 the principal at risk liquidity
provider we support the institutional
trading of crypto and we don't face
retail investors our clients are the
largest banks and trading firms globally
we had the opportunity to work with
Alameda earlier in the year which we had
turned down you know we take a very
conservative approach to risk and they
just didn't fit our risk profile
just a few days later enter stage rights
CZ
Chang Pang Zhao he runs binance which is
the other really big kind of global
cryptocurrency exchange he tweets that
he is going to be selling his Holdings
or finances Holdings of the ftt token
due to some recent Revelations and the
price of these tokens really starts
cratering for fast this really was the
moment that caused widespread Market
panic and that sent the price of ftt
absolutely plunging was just watching
the graph and it was going further and
further down Finance is one of the major
holders other than FTX and Alameda
themselves and we know from the balance
sheet of Alameda that value of ftt is
kind of integral to the whole financial
structure of the sandbagment freed
Empire very quickly after the CEO of
Alameda Caroline Ellison came out and
said we'll buy it it kind of smelled a
bit funny something's going on here why
do they want to hold the ftt token at a
certain level if they could keep ftt's
price supported then they wouldn't have
to kind of accept that the value of
their own assets were falling and that
they were potentially insolvent then
that failed
within just a few days FTX is
effectively running out of money this is
a bank with nothing backing it if you do
not trust that your money is safe it's
very easy for a background to develop 24
hours later on November 7 Sam tweets
that FTX is fine and assets are fine he
was saying right up to the very last
minute FTX was fine or the FTX us was
fine or that you know this is all just a
bit understanding insolvency rumors
plaguing crypto exchange FTX are being
denied by CEO Sam Bateman freed after a
coindesk investigation revealed the
balance sheet of FTX sister company
Alameda research was loaded with ftx's
Native exchange token ftt on November
the 8th CZ said that he was going to
acquire FTX which was just completely
insane you've got the head of the
world's biggest crypto company saying
that he's going to buy his Rivals crypto
company Sam is Dead in public trying to
reassure people and people had a lot of
faith in FTX and sambanga freed my name
is Carol Alexander I'm a crypto expert I
had a small portfolio of crypto so that
I can teach the students uh what's
happening on exchanges my decision to
put funds on fgx was just a personal
connection of somebody who met some
bankman freed and a lot of people
recommended FTA I first heard about the
problems with FTX when I was out in
Barcelona at the Quant mines Congress
it's an annual
um Summit for mathematical Finance
everybody there was
was really surprised none of us thought
it was going to be serious only takes 24
hours one day later for Susie to have a
look under the bonnet look at the books
and actually decide that no he's not
going to buy FTX and meanwhile inside
the company people would describe just
total chaos employees are quitting left
right and Center Sam is trying to kind
of steer the sinking ship the events
unfolded very very quickly we tried to
withdraw some funds from the exchange
and those withdrawals weren't processed
FTX suspends withdrawals and in a memo
to his employees SPF says that they're
trying to raise funds it was when he
stopped withdrawals that was the biggest
thing I thought oh you know there's
something wrong here you have hedge
funds you have various Market
participants in crypto saying yeah Sam
can't get my money back here I wasn't
giving you this money I was just trading
through you I didn't realize that you
were going to take these funds away from
me we had about 9 million of assets on
FTX uh leading up to the time in which
they suspended withdrawals we felt
comfortable that we could absorb the
losses if if one or two or three
exchanges go down on the day that FTX
you know stopped paying back its
customers which is effectively the day
it's collapsed that morning major
sophisticated investors in crypto were
still telling me safest houses it cannot
go down what was going through my mind
was first and foremost how do we
mitigate the risk to The Firm
secondly what are the knock-on effects
for the market right people having their
cash tied up at FTX meant you know they
weren't in the same financial position
as they might have been
foreign
million dollars U.S
um yeah
I think Sam probably still thought that
FTX could be salvaged but of course he
was wrong FTX filed some bankruptcy in
New York and Sam resigns as chief
executive I've never seen anything
unravel in that sort of space of time
before it's had a significant effect on
my life I couldn't sleep and eat
properly for at least few few weeks it
was just basically stolen overnight
it's just been difficult
[Music]
million dollars worth of ftx's customer
money is disappeared since then that
number has grown there's an alleged 8
billion hole of customer money that is
just missing unaccounted for I don't
think we've we've given up on the
possibility of getting funds back but we
have written them down from an
accounting perspective
I filed a class action lawsuit so I was
the lead plaintiff the international
plaintiff against all the people who
profited and enabled the ledge forward
the celebrity promoters I felt that I
had to do something thankfully I've I've
had a supportive wife and I you know
kept me going mentally I've been
probably more difficult I would say
after FTX files for bankruptcy Sam is
still in the Bahamas where he lives and
where he was running FTX from he started
to tweet a lot he's out here tweeting
long thread trying to explain what
happened and how desperately he's trying
to work to get customers money back and
how sorry he is all the talk online is
when are they going to arrest this guy
but in this intervening period
sambachman freed hits the media circuit
hard after apologizing profusely on
Twitter he talks to the New York Times
he talks to Good Morning America
I did not know that there is any
improper use of customer funds he
eventually talks to the Ft as well his
message is absolutely consistent he says
over and over again I up and I'm
really sorry and I didn't mean to do
anything fraudulent have I done
something fraudulent I didn't mean to do
anything fraudulent you can just imagine
his lawyers just tearing their hair out
like please Sam for the love of God will
you shut up and stop talking to
journalists there were a number of
things I was paying close attention to
in terms of trading volume and revenue
and liquidity I wasn't in terms of
balances or positional risk Sam gave us
an interview shortly before he was
arrested he said to me okay how about
three o'clock in the morning I think you
would necessarily he starts out sitting
looking normal at a camera but he's
always moving and he's kind of Shifting
around the camera angle's changing he's
clearly he's moving his laptop he's
giving this interview from his bed he
would ask him questions that you know
you would think are pretty
straightforward every answer starts with
I'm not sure I don't have access to this
I don't have access to that let me take
a step back
there may be discussions I don't know
about I do remember that there were some
discussions around alameda's position
um I don't remember numbers from those I
don't remember numbers being said I'm
not sure they weren't yeah I think
that's all I got he was trying to manage
the FTX narrative in a way that really
put his apology at the Forefront but at
no point as he's saying this was fraud
or this was on purpose it's just one big
mistake it's just one huge
misunderstanding this is just not how
anybody ever behaves when they are in
the kind of legal position that that Sam
was you do not talk to the press and any
lawyer would tell you that
finally on December the 12th Sunday
rested in the Bahamas initially he
resists extradition the conditions in
the Jailer Bahamas are notoriously
difficult he didn't really want to be
extradited to the United States but I
think after a short period in jail in
the Bahamas that idea became a little
bit more appealing to him
[Music]
flown to the U.S
come on
he appeared before a judge he's pleaded
not guilty they raise a 250 million
dollar bail for him to effectively go
and sit in his parents house in
California for as long as it takes until
this goes to trial he is charged with
eight counts by the southern district of
New York which includes wire fraud
conspiracy to commit wire fraud campaign
Finance violations the SEC and the cftc
who are two major Regulators in the
states have also brought charges against
Sam that there is a future where Sam
potentially spends the rest of his life
in prison this company is really unlike
any other
Jacks didn't have a board there were no
adults in the room there was no one
overseeing what was going on inside no
risk management procedures that didn't
have the corporate structure perhaps
people would conventionally imagine a
whole empire you know including Alameda
and the various arms of FTX were all
kind of being run from a very small
inner circle of people close to Saint
Bergman freed right in the middle of the
circle is SPF and he ran the show then
you've got Caroline Ellison who is chief
executive of Alameda research SBF and
Caroline had an alleged on off romantic
relationship for many months they shared
the same Penthouse apartment in the
Bahamas lived together worked together
was super super close she has since
resigned and pleaded guilty to fraud
charges and is cooperating with law
enforcement in the states and then
you've got Sam Trabuco who was the
co-head of Alameda research alongside
Caroline until the summer when he
resigned and he ran the trading
strategies at Alameda for a while and
you then have Gary Wang Chief technology
officer and co-founder of not only FTX
but also animated research this you know
speaks to the incestuousness essentially
of both companies that were meant to be
separate and he and Sam go way back they
went to math account together and then
they were also College roommates when
they were both at MIT Gary Wang is also
cooperating with law enforcement in the
states after pleading guilty to fraud
charges and then you've got nishad Singh
who was also very close to SBF he you
know shared multiple apartments with Sam
again this speaks to the fact that both
Alameda and FTX which were meant to be
separate companies really in many ways
weren't they lived together they ate
together they did whatever else it is
together
everything wall
yeah the fast food the grocery
deliveries when I was in the Bahamas I
spoke to a person who worked for a food
delivery company and they'd be ordering
maybe 500 bucks worth of takeout every
night it was just sort of free-flowing
money and getting Amazon packages flown
in from Miami night sale and beach
resorts if you're a nerd and you're
working with a bunch of other nerds and
you're changing the world through sheer
nerdery you feel pretty powerful no one
outside the Inner Circle knew really
what was going on there was only a
handful maybe five or six people at the
top who knew the inner workings of FTX
and Alameda and the crossover there
everything that happened with FTX and
Sam really highlights the need for a
distributed management structure no one
person should be able to make every
decision about a company and also there
should be multiple layers of governance
within a company it's not just crypto
Traders large and small that have lost
Venture Capital firms professional
investors that had helped get FTX off
the ground have had to write down their
Investments some of them worth you know
hundreds of millions of dollars down to
a big fat zero the one that everyone
thinks of is Sequoia Capital there are
VC firms and there are VC firms Sequoia
is a very serious BC firm and it went to
the effort of posting on its website an
article running to 13 800 words talking
about what a genius Sam is how he has
the status of Legend all of these
Venture Capital investors say look where
it surprises everybody we did the due
diligence on FTX
how
there's a great attraction for big
institutions to go into crypto although
it's high risk it can be very high
returns particularly when the odds are
stuck in your favor their balance sheets
are so large that they can afford to
take risks they don't need to do the due
diligence they just need to get in there
early they write down the investment the
people who get hurt are the retail
investors they call you can't write down
you know
well I mean I'm a good invite now 2.1
billion dollars okay and then the other
guy he's like come on many institutional
investors
you know parked due diligence
essentially over fomo the fear of not
being part of this new technology you
know people are calling it like the new
internet that probably propelled some of
these investors to not look deep enough
and just say hey take my money it's also
possible you know some investors
returned away because they were asking
questions that FTX didn't want to answer
when you have a lineup around the block
of other investors who are ready to
write your check today you don't need to
go with the investor who's asking
difficult questions one big VC investor
shemathaya says that he was approached
about putting some money to work in FTX
and he said okay look this is
interesting there's a few things we'd
want you to do differently we'd want you
to have a board we'd want you to have
some sort of oversight and he says the
response from FTX was quote go
yourself backing from really big name
Venture Capital firms really big name
investors really matters because it
pulls in
are the people it pulls in the hedge
funds it pulls in the retail Traders
ftx's Auditors were not in the big four
but they were armanino and pragamatis in
the US and armanino is one of the top 20
accounting firms in the US by revenue
and the fact that they didn't catch on
to any of this it just shows a complete
failure auditing crypto is really
difficult you have various tokens that
are worth whatever it is the company
says that they're worth you know the big
name Auditors are generally too nervous
to get involved in this space it's
really incumbent on these crypto
exchanges and these other crypto
companies to convince Big Time Auditors
that they should lend their legitimacy
to these companies and you know until
that happens these Legacy issues of
transparency and safety of customer
funds they're going to persist we have
filled though more due diligence
questionnaires in the last 10 weeks and
probably we did in in the year before
that but I think that's a really good
thing right I think it's really good
that the counterparties and the clients
that we're facing and are diving into
details they're understanding the risks
that they're taking we really need to
work to build up that level of trust
back in the industry but I'm very you
know encouraged by the fact that people
are taking the time to do it there's
also the question of Regulation with
crypto Regulators don't know entirely
how and what to do with it how to
classify it unfortunately it's taken a
catastrophic collapse of one of the
biggest companies in the industry to
prompt Regulators to start thinking
seriously about what they should do to
protect consumers
that FDF
DX close to getting cftc regulation
they'd applied they had an excellent
margin model that took account of very
high margin requirements and we're not
going to allow their customers 100 times
leverage Finance even offers 125 times
leverage on some products in some
jurisdictions
so fgx was a completely different animal
this is FTX us to binance FTX
International which is the main part of
the business it's much bigger than the
US business and is where the problems
seem to have come from along with
Alameda is based in the Bahamas which
has a tailor-made regulatory regime that
they rolled out for digital assets they
see this industry that's booming and
they don't want to miss out it's just
not the kind of thing that could happen
if these companies are being regulated
as tightly as companies that perform
equivalent functions in major Financial
Market Regulators are so far behind
there's a lack of knowledge and a lack
of resources these exchanges they call
themselves self-regulated which
basically means not regulated at all
there will come a time when Regulators
eventually get their act together and
they stop platforms like binance
operating as Shadow Banks their own
blockchain nft marketplaces limit order
books brokerage custody and clearing and
settlements I mean how do you regulate
something like that it's got to stop we
want to partner with Regulators to
create a framework that is fit for
purpose for crypto and digital assets
having worked in traditional Finance for
a fairly long period of time I think
it's important that we don't try to
pigeonhole crypto and digital assets
into that existing regulatory framework
as soon as you regulate something just
like with the Venture Capital firms that
is stamp of approval this thing has some
sort of regulatory oversight it's safe I
can put my money to work here
that's not a kind of Indemnity that
regulators and governments have wanted
to give to crypto Sam was really at the
Forefront of lobbying Democrats in the
US talking to regulators and lobbying
them to change the crypto regulatory
landscape the money that was flowing
into FTX some of this money has ended up
as political donations a lot of this is
to the Democratic party and so one of
the big lines that people throw about is
well you know obviously Congress never
looked properly into FTX because he was
pumping money into the Democrats it
turns out the firm was also pumping
money into the Republicans so a lot of
folks saw what Sam was doing and accused
him effectively of trying to Lobby not
for crypto's interests in Washington but
for ftxs and Sam's interests
[Music]
U.S prosecutors say this is one of the
biggest frauds in American Financial
history the most insane alleged fraud to
have taken place blowing Enron and
others out of the water the failure of
FTX hasn't really affected the price of
Bitcoin people will cling onto these
coins for dear life people in the crypto
industry say it's just an FTX problem
it's an SPF problem this is a crypto
issue it's not just an FTX issue Sam was
the poster child of this crypto industry
personally I'm just taking a break
people who want to invest I don't I
don't see why you know they should stop
what's happened to FTX tells you that
the infrastructure here that's built on
top of an asset which to be clear has an
intrinsic value of zero is incredibly
shaky if FTX can disappear in a
fortnight then any of them can 2023 is
going to be a year where the crypto
industry writ large and many Chief
Executives of big crypto companies are
going to have to deal with regulatory
scrutiny that perhaps they wouldn't have
had to have dealt with if it wasn't for
ftx's collapse in November this is a
cool abortion retail for investors who
were jumping into FTX for fear of
missing out you have to do due diligence
first and foremost you have to check
what's going on the crypto Bros have
been able to say ah it's just fud fear
uncertainty doubt just ignore it turns
out everyone needed a whole lot more fod
Sam what he's trying to do is say
this was all an accident and what
prosecutors will try and pin him on is
that this is fraud
ible
[Music]
thank you